hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
and I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch
the trailer for the call of the wild
from 20th Century Fox and Disney and yes
Youtube upload her this video is for
kids mmm
kid-friendly son of a mother
in YouTube and they're weird government
in-laws if everyone wants to give we're
in the ones gonna be able to do what
ever wanted a god did the bends and
supremacist America Harrison Ford what
the heck man UConn is a dangerous place
sounds like Harrison Ford
[Music]
interesting CGI toys yeah go out
[Music]
see what's out there
whoa Oh save her that dogs gonna die
from hypothermia
[Music]
as much as he believes in you
you say [ __ ]
[Music]
adventure of a lifetime
I sleep for two days I forgot that Jack
London book was a major blockbuster
that's right that's right I got about
the thrills and high stakes that's why
we we read that keep us I think I
remember why I forgot because I didn't
read it oh that would make sense yeah I
believe I just cliff noted it and turn
in an essay to mr. Peugeot so oh hey
who's now mrs. green by the way huge fan
of the channel yes we keep up with her
on a regular basis I can see this being
what Harrison Ford really fantasizes
about doing hahaha yeah real Harrison
Ford in the script oh it just so happens
to line up with the call the wild book I
guess we have a property then I fell in
love with an Asian woman in the
mountains with my puppy and my beer I'm
curious and excited that Harrison Ford
was into doing this Harrison Ford's a
funny performer to me now because I feel
like all he wants to do is just chill
but every now and again he still pops up
in a movie and it looks like he I don't
know I'm interested to see him just do
the solo thing a little bit ha ha ha ha
ha
pun intended there I meant that pun and
planned it the parts where he's alone
and having I feel like he's gonna have
to spend a lot of this movie acting
against CGI or or the elements and so
that seems those are clearly real dog
yes yes and that's an acting role that
you gotta want to sing I mean it's
better to CGI the animals and put them
in real peril you know what I mean
really throw your thugs and yeah there's
some questionable CGI in this but you
know I think for a family driven film
and then hooking in the adults for the
Harrison Ford experience so I think what
Harrison Ford is the lead role when he's
the lead he shows up he plays he cares
it looks like he really cares to me
here this time around now this looks
really sweet I mean it looks like a
great family film a good adventure you
know it looks better to me than those
dogs purpose journey movies yeah yeah it
feels like totally akin to that at the
same time the adventure is much more
boisterous I can move past the CGI
whatever yeah it looks like it could
give you both that and some of that man
versus the elements intensity that you
know the book does kind of have but not
on a you know the grey or you know that
kind of intensity scale really hope they
go super oblique by the amateurs yeah
hair is something double down on peril
yes to saw one of his legs off just a
feed buck for that last stretch of
winter and especially from the vague
amounts that I do remember about the
book I mean it's not necessarily like
blockbuster but there is a lot of
sprawling you know elemental adventure
you know a justification for a lot of
these big landscapes that they're empty
seems to really be doubling down with
their dog movies now I know with lady
and the [ __ ] stamp and now the call of
the wild style let's get let's get some
other ones let's get a live action
Oliver and company oh it's gonna live
action Aristocats all dogs go to heaven
no we are talking about dogs right now
cats never learn their place they just
think this is oh this is the Internet
this is our place but no that's why you
were cast as stereotypical Asian cats
and Lady and the [ __ ] yeah I understand
that it's why you caused controversy I'd
be curious to know if they use the real
dog at all because there are times where
it looks real but a lot of the shots are
clearly not a real dog yeah even in the
simple shots something we're just not
like oh there's crazy stuff attacking
just little things just like when the
dog is breaking off of the leash in that
one moment oh well yeah there's a little
bit of extra oomph in the facial
expression especially in that moment
definitely or if it is a real dog and
then they you know digital around it for
certain moments especially because the
heart of this movie is supposed to be
Harrison Ford bonding with this animal
finding lie
right back into him because clearly this
man wants I don't know the book cuz man
wants the isolate himself from humanity
and connection in total and then finding
a purpose to keep on living and finding
the soul within from the life that a dog
can give you finding his best I think
it's important to feel it the dog is
real important to me yeah yeah that's a
great call of the wild hahaha but I yeah
mm-hmm would you I don't get the joke oh
you know cuz um you know the wild mmm
the wild that show the wild yeah I'm not
help no joke is going terrifically what
do you want you want to play right now
oh that's the real called a wild right
there look at that guy I want to see a
movie about cats leading a sled or some
kind yeah I don't know I feel like they
could easily it's a conundrum for a
movie like this because the dog has to
be kind of a main character so what do
you do and I feel like there is a way to
do it both practically and CG everything
in this trailer looked like it was
probably mostly CG on that on buck I
feel like the the marriage of real dog
to CG has gotten better in recent times
I mean I haven't seen lady in the [ __ ]
but it certainly looked better than it
didn't like cats and dogs or something
like that so I don't know yeah but that
is important if it's good if it feels
like a completely fake dog it's gonna
hurt the movie I listen to everything
you said listening to you right now
alright guys well are you excited for
the call of the wild
have you seen into the wild kids I
recommend ya get on your daddy's Netflix
account and watch wild things sorry Neve
Campbell and Denise Richards as soon as
you can why all the hogs is a good movie
- Oh The Wild Thornberrys they made a
movie that was a classic
wildin out there you go an mtv great
show we've fought the wild berries and
the movie trivia Schmo down did we
almost beat them - I'm out of wild
subscribe to the real rejects click that
notification bell I'm going out of town
into the wild oh by the way that's one
thing I really love - it looks like I
shot most of this on location and I love
those scenic shots I feel like that'd be
great to absorb in a movie theater look
a really positive point and I would like
to end this with a patron of the day
shout out a man named Bailey Reichert
he's a new patron he's been watching our
reactions for a while
Nana's from Texas so you know he's down
and go nasty into the wild mm-hmm hey
buddy
since it's your first shout out I looked
up your name get ready you probably
don't even know what it means as most
people don't know though name of
meanings of their names berry cleaning
clearing berry clearing bailiff city
fortifications oh wow
that's this great I bet your parents
read the meaning and said we got a name
our son Bailey clearings filled with
berries our beautiful and delicious plus
I mean cities that are strong always
yeah I don't think they were like we
should named after a grand power or
something or like or our favorite drink
we want a son who represents berry
clearing or you know people who regulate
things going on in a court hearing
Reichert your last name stands for brave
or strong person and to venture off into
the wild streets of Austin Texas you
need to be a brave or strong person
let's face it it's not safe over there I
hope you move over here although the
rent is all a lot more expensive so
maybe you should just stay where you're
at
Bailey Ryker thank you so much for being
here dude I hope you have a happy
Thanksgiving I hope you'd be safe thanks
for being part of our patreon page and
shouts out to your mom she did good